good morning hello good morning how are
you really well thank you for taking
time out of your busy schedule to have a
bit of a chat with us how's the Year
been since winning the team bridge
sports personality of the year last year
and obviously pretty crazy I also went
back to uni so kind of done the whole
graduating thing this year as well and
I've actually got back from Cyprus early
morning yesterday so I've just been
trying to wash and repack who I go to
Hong Kong tomorrow and you did well in
Cyprus don't you yeah there's a really
good trip actually we got and the team
gold which is awesome the girls got a
gold in the falls and use me I got a
single silver and triple silver as well
so it's pretty successful and just to
mention away from the balls you've done
rather well Reggie waiting as well I
believe yeah I got to you wanna E&E so
and that was nice it's just been a
really crazy year so that graduate and
was just a nice finish to really sit
back for a couple of days a bit of
washing stock up on some food and then
you off to Hong Kong what something that
it's a world champion of champions there
which I qualify for last year winning
even singles and we've also got a world
mixed pairs which I'm playing with the
other guy called Steve who won the
England singles as well so that should
be a really good event I've heard on the
grapevine that you're heading off to
Australia is that going to happen next
year I'm hoping it is yeah I'm still
kind of waiting for confirmation for
everything obviously the visas and why
it's quite a complicated process but
I've been wanting to do it for a while
now so yeah maybe what was the reason
behind that is that to do the fact that
the bowls is kind of a more popular
sport over there well yeah I mean it's
pretty much a professional sport you can
get paid for it I'd need to have a job
on the side as well but I think it's
just a new lifestyle choice for me and a
new challenge really because I love the
country so hopefully a workout is it
frustrating for you and obviously you
know you've won the Commonwealth gold
which is an amazing achievement you're
only 22 32 so young um but bowls isn't
kind of big sport in this country it is
it frustrating for you to kind of think
sometimes like I wish I was a hundred
meter runner or something like that
because by this point you'd probably
like a million Avenue and yeah I mean I
play ball so I love it not for the money
and I think it's such a an enjoyable
sport for me now obviously it's
frustrating I mean it's not like
want to get rich from bowls but just a
little bit of help would would go a long
way really and having to work full time
to support yourself as well and having
the expectation to do you really well
when you go away for the tournament's is
a lot of pressure so yeah I mean couple
of hundred quid here and there wouldn't
give miss but you're obviously very
passionate about the sport and you're
still trying to get out there and get
the game out to the masses to try and
make it more popularly yeah I mean I've
really worked hard this year to try and
obviously change the face the bowls i
suppose and try and make it a bit more
of a popular sport and something that
people can see as a sport for all ages
because it has got negative stereotype
obviously I'm only 22 band playing it
for a long time now and I've certainly
got a lot of pleasure from it and I'll
really enjoy it so hopefully other
people give it a chance to and obviously
you've done brilliantly in your field in
the field of bold the so many talented
athletes in team bridges as we've seen
tonight at the award ceremony of
sparring sportsmen and women who were
perhaps chasing their dream I think you
know you get out of life what you put
into it and that was certainly something
that I learnt quite early on and I've
got really supportive parents which made
a massive difference to me and I think
you know anyone if you really want
something that badly and you've got a
dream then just go for it and you'll get
there in the end I think you know I'm
proof of that hopefully and I've worked
really hard for what I've got today so
you know it is possible so just keep
tracing chasing these dreams I suppose